water earth fire
you guys are not gonna believe this team
avatar is back hey everybody is Charlie
this is not a drill team avatar is back
and I'm not talking about Legend of
Korra I'm not talking about a new series
set in the future I'm talking about a
new avatar the last airbender Aang's
series coming to Netflix in the next
couple of years they even released this
first teaser so this is just a confirmed
that this is going to be young Aang they
don't want you to be confused and think
that they're going to be doing adult
Aang after the events of the original
series they just announced it so I'll
explain what's going on but it is time
to officially freak out it's been at
least a couple years since I've done an
avatar video so if you're new to the
channel because of this video be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos of
course I will do episode videos when it
gets here so a lot of you have been
hearing the news from various sources
I'll explain what's exactly going on
Mike and Bryan are back they're gonna be
show running the new series together so
team break is back important detail to
Jeremy Zuckerman the person that did all
the music for avatar the last airbender
and for a legend of korra he's coming
back to do the music for this new avatar
revival series so in real life team
avatar is also back now they didn't say
when the release date is going to be
they just announced that Mike and Bryan
are on board it's going to be a
live-action revival series meaning that
what they might do is just retell the
original story doing it live action
effectively wiping the abomination that
was that live-action last airbender
movie off the map if you haven't already
we can just forget that that existed
right now there are a lot of people that
were confused too people thought that
they were actually just doing that no
that is not what's happening imagine
when they made the Avatar movie several
years ago imagine if Mike and Bryan had
been doing that and they had done it the
right way they haven't announced to the
cast is yet but this is a statement that
they both released were thrilled for the
opportunity to helm this live-action
adaptation of Avatar The Last Airbender
we can't wait to realize Aang's world as
cinematically as we always imagined it
to be and with a culturally appropriate
non-white wash cast it's a
once-in-a-lifetime chance to build upon
everyone's great work
the original animated series and go even
deeper into the character's story action
and world building Netflix is wholly
dedicated to manifesting our vision for
this retelling and were incredibly
grateful to be partnering with them so a
lot of you probably know about the
different comic book series that they've
released which sort of add to the story
after the events of Susan's comment in
the season 3 finale so what happened is
is the original series was always
planned to be three seasons they did
about 20 episodes give or take and it
was just meant to be this adventure
series in the vein of the original
Dragon Ball series you know people
traveling around the world solving this
big problem in this really incredible
mythology so that wasn't canceled by
Nickelodeon they always planned on doing
that number of episodes so it was done
they went on they did some comic books
eventually a Nickelodeon came back to
them and said you know what we need more
of this do you have any more ideas
within the Avatar universe that's why
they did the Korra sequel series so
they're like okay well we know we don't
want to do Aang again but we do have
this idea for another avatar set in the
future it was the same situation with
the Korra series they had a set amount
of story that they wanted to tell once
they finished with book 4 that was all
they wanted to do so that's why the
series ended it wasn't canceled by
Nickelodeon they just announced a new
Korra comic book series which continues
that story is the same thing that they
did with the Avatar series so within
this news release though they do
specifically say retelling of that
original avatar story so because a lot
of Netflix series are say 10 to 13
episodes what they might do is because
special effects have just gotten really
good an avatar would be a very special
effects driven TV show just because of
the way they use their powers what they
might do is just break the story up into
five to seven seasons because the
original series was about 20 episodes
per season they obviously could break
this up into halves so think about it
this way the first season might just be
the first half of book 1 where they have
to go to the fire temple by the winter
solstice to learn from Avatar Roku
about sozin's comet that was the whole
first big arc and comes out of the ice
they're being chased down by the Fire
Nation and by Zuko separately they learn
from King Bumi that they have to make it
to avatar Roku's temple
learn about sozin's comet by the winter
solstice or they won't get the
information that they need that was sort
of them setting up the rest of the
entire series every single episode what
the stakes were thousands comet is
coming you have to defeat him before
that happens because once the comet
comes he'll be effectively invincible so
in order to be able to fully actualize
as the avatar aang had to go around and
learn about all the different bending
styles so season two of this new series
might be him going to the northern water
temple to learn waterbending from the
Masters so they sort of did that for
that last live-action movie imagine a
completely different version of that
that was them condensing 20 episodes
effectively into a two-hour movie
imagine them doing all those episodes
again slightly different but the same
basic story so like you would still do
the Blue Spirit you would still do stuff
like the fortune teller but it might not
play down the exact same way I don't
think it's gonna be copy-paste scripts
from the original episodes for those of
you that are worried that they won't be
able to pull this off in live-action
just keep in mind that every year that
goes by special effects get better and
better so the stuff that you see in the
big movies like the big Marvel movies
all those crazy effects it gets super
easy to do those within a couple years
of those movies coming out so by the
time the series gets here they'll be
able to do infinity war level effects on
a TV level netflix budget and because
netflix is so worried about Disney
pulling all of its content off of
Netflix and Warner Brothers and all the
other studios that is why it's
overspending on a lot of these big epic
series it's begging on these being super
popular so people will want to stay with
Netflix to get this stuff but I think
the real key here is isn't getting the
original creative Mike and Bryan if it
weren't Mike and Bryan doing it then I
would say maybe there's cause for
concern but because it's basically the
entire original avatar series team
coming back to do this I think we're
pretty safe it's not gonna be a
live-action Dragon Ball situation it's
not gonna be a live-action Fullmetal
Alchemist situation do not worry about
that kind of stuff what's probably gonna
happen is is right now because they just
announced it
they're probably blocking what the story
is going to be how they're gonna break
the episodes up then they'll convene a
writers room they'll start writing the
episodes then they'll start casting the
beauty
this is is that they seem like they're
gonna be pretty open about the process
because it's been so long and they want
fans to come back like hey remember you
loved avatar so much we're doing that
again please come back and watch it
Sifu ki soo probably gonna come back and
help advise them on their martial arts
if you don't remember Sifu casue was the
person that helped them develop the
styles of bending and the martial arts
that they would use during the series
and during Korra they haven't announced
where they're going to film it I assume
it's gonna be somewhere in Europe or
East Asia or New Zealand somewhere that
looks like the world of Avatar because I
don't think it's a big problem in terms
of locations or getting the actors that
they want Netflix wants this to be as
good as it can be so whatever you have
in your mind is a really awesome a
live-action version they're probably
gonna get pretty close to that so they
make it say like five six seven seasons
who knows maybe they'll also do a
live-action Korra series after that I
think it just depends on how things go
the first couple of seasons with this
but they'll just keep doing this as long
as people keep watching so if you want
to support it it's gonna be a couple
years before the episodes actually get
here but right now the original avatar
series isn't available for streaming
pretty much anywhere the only way you
can get it is the occasional reruns on
Nickelodeon site buying it on iTunes I
do think that they have the 1080p
remasters on iTunes they just did the
complete avatar series blu-ray release
they also did the same thing for Korra
so you can go out to Best Buy or pretty
much any store that sells blu-rays and
get those right now and they are
remasters they did tune everything up
for 1080p on the original series so it
looks way way better a lot of you been
asking me about that new Dragon Prince
series because a lot of the people that
worked on Avatar The Last Airbender and
Korra are working on that series even
though it's not connected to avatar
there are a lot of Easter eggs for that
like remember during the ember island
players episode
Zuko says my mother used to take me to
see them they butchered love amongst the
Dragons every year because the person
that wrote the ember island players
episode wrote this episode of the dragon
prince you actually see this girl
reading that book love amongst the
Dragons but just to be clear that's
completely separate from the Avatar
series let me know in the comments
though how do you want them to break up
and
we tell the original Avatar The Last
Airbender series in live-action do you
think that they'll just break it up in
the first season will be them going to
see Avatar Roku to learn about Susan's
comment and then they'll just do that
same thing for book 1 book 2 and book 3
because within their news release Mike
and Bryan did say that they're going
deeper on all the characters than they
did in the original series so I'm just
interested to see how this is all going
to break down but no worries it's
probably not going to shoot til next
year sometime meaning that we wouldn't
see the episodes to the year after that
so it'll probably be here 2020 before we
get those episodes no worries but click
here to rewatch that big Captain Marvel
trailer from yesterday a billion more
times and click here to learn about the
Avengers TV series that they just
announced
it's crazy thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]